lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
encontrar una definición más rigurosa
para la continuidad y la idea general de
continuidad o la intuición que tenemos
este concepto es que una función es
continua en un punto si podemos dibujar
la gráfica de esa función en ese punto
sin despegar el lápiz del papel qué
significa esto bueno lo que acabo de
decir no es riguroso en lo absoluto y
quiere decir que si imaginamos este
punto que llamamos ce y podemos dibujar
la gráfica en ese punto sin levantar el
lápiz entonces esa función es continua
en el punto c comienzo a dibujar la
gráfica aquí y continúo dibujando la sin
levantar el lápiz para nada puedo decir
que en este punto la función es continua
pero si la función es diferente a esta y
se ve así digamos que está definida
hasta llegar a este punto y luego brinca
y continúa desde acá va a ser imposible
dibujar esta gráfica sin levantar el
lápiz de la pantalla
toco la pantalla toco la pantalla toco
la pantalla y cómo puedo seguir
dibujando esto sin levantar el lápiz no
me queda más remedio que levantar el
lápiz y continuar dibujando desde acá
esta es una forma intuitiva para saber
que esta gráfica no es continua en este
punto pero vamos a encontrar una
definición formal para la continuidad y
veremos si nos parece intuitiva la
definición formal de continuidad y vamos
a comenzar con la definición de
continuidad en un punto
la función f es continua en x igual a c
si y sólo si esto lo represento con esta
fecha doble el límite en ambos lados de
fx cuando x tiende a c es igual a fcc
esto podría parecernos muy técnico pero
analicemos lo que dice aquí quiere decir
que si el límite cuando x tiende a c
desde la izquierda y desde la derecha de
fx es igual al valor de esa función
evaluada en ese entonces las funciones
continua en ese punto veamos tres
ejemplos veremos un ejemplo en donde
parece que la función si es continua en
ese punto y veremos otros ejemplos en
donde la función no sea continua en ese
punto para ver si aplica esta definición
más rigurosa dibujamos esta función y la
definimos como ye igual a fx nos
interesa el comportamiento en este punto
cuando x es igual a ser este es el eje x
y este el eje ya dijimos que nos
interesa el comportamiento en el punto
ce y vean que usando la definición
intuitiva podemos dibujar esta función
en el punto c
a levantar el lápiz por lo que parece
continua aquí no vemos ningún salto aquí
o discontinuidad alguna podríamos decir
que toda la gráfica está conectada ahora
pensemos en esta definición el límite
cuando x tiende a c desde la izquierda
pareciera que tiende a fcc y el límite
desde la derecha también parece que
tiende a fcc la función está definida
cuando x es igual a c y ese es el valor
al que tienen los límites desde la
izquierda y desde la derecha todo se ve
bien en este escenario ahora veamos otro
escenario en donde tengamos que levantar
el lápiz al dibujar la función cuando x
es igual a c vamos a dibujar una función
en donde tenemos lo que se conoce como
un punto de discontinuidad aunque no es
necesario conocer la terminología formal
en este momento digamos que tenemos aquí
el punto c y la función está así y que
este es el valor de la función cuando x
es igual a c este es el valor de fcc
pero cuál es el límite cuando x tiende a
c este es un límite bilateral si se
acerca desde la izquierda parece que
tiende a este
y si se acerca desde la derecha parece
que también tiende a este mismo valor
que llamaremos l y el valor de l es
diferente a fcc en este caso usando la
definición formal la función no es
continua en x igual hacer esto podemos
confirmarlo con el método intuitivo al
tratar de dibujar la función sin
levantar el lápiz el lápiz toca la
pantalla toca la pantalla toca la
pantalla oops si quiero seguir dibujando
la gráfica voy a tener que levantar el
lápiz para ir a este punto de acá arriba
y luego volver a levantar el lápiz para
continuar aquí abajo
la definición rigurosa nos da la misma
conclusión el límite cuando x tiende a
ser desde la izquierda y desde la
derecha tiende a un valor diferente al
de la función evaluada en el punto c por
lo que esta función no es continua
veamos otro escenario imaginemos una
función en donde no existe el límite
desde la izquierda ni desde la derecha
dibujo los ejes este es x este es y la
función se ve así primero por acá y
luego sigue por acá abajo
aquí está el punto c este es el valor de
fcc pareciera que el valor del límite
cuando extiende desde la izquierda o
desde valores menores hace el límite
tiende a fcc pero si vemos el límite
cuando x tiende a c desde la derecha
entonces parece que tiende a un valor
diferente de fcc llamemos l a este valor
l no es igual a fcc por lo que aquí no
existe límite bilateral nfc el valor del
límite desde la izquierda es diferente
al valor del límite desde la derecha así
que el límite no existe en el punto cero
esto definitivamente no es continuo esto
también coincide con la prueba de
levantar el lápiz al dibujar la gráfica
si dibujamos esto tengo el lápiz tocando
la pantalla sigue tocando la pantalla
hasta llegar a aquí en donde no puedo
seguir dibujando la gráfica sin despegar
el lápiz lo levantó lo bajo aquí y sigo
dibujando confirmado esta función no es
continua lo comprobamos con el método
intuitivo de levantar el lápiz y también
con la definición formal
acaso el límite bilateral ni siquiera
existe en x ac así que definitivamente
no es continua y en este otro caso
aunque existe el límite bilateral el
límite tiene un valor diferente al de la
función en ese punto por lo que la
función tampoco es continua aquí el
único escenario en donde la función es
continua es cuando el límite bilateral
tiende al mismo valor y ese valor es el
valor de la función en ese punto si esto
se cumple entonces la función es
continua nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo